This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
这是一档I-Heart播客节目。真人真事，如假包换。2%。这就是当电梯和自动扶梯同时存在时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立适应力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历风雨后，变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. that's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《2%》。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，这对我和我而言都是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black. black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。黑人同胞们。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Look Back at it》。
Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hardway》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖恩斯。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的心路历程，进行一些在其他地方绝对无法开诚布公的真诚对话，但在这里，你是在与一位经验丰富的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。这向全世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。
Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg Alessian.
欢迎在iHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听并学习《Learn the Hardway》。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。还有另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·阿莱西亚。
Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
迈克尔·兰吉尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终将面临法律制裁。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《二字头心理学》，在这个播客中，我们将探讨20多岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s, of your 20s. Before we begin, a brief trigger warning that this episode does deal with some fairly in-depth discussions around weight loss, weight gain, appearance, and eating disorders. So please do just take a second to consider whether you are in a healthy mental space, a healthy mindset to be listening to this right now. This episode will still be here in a few days, in a week, in a few months, so you can always return to it when the time is right, when the time is better. let's get into it. Today we are going to be talking about a pretty vulnerable topic, one that has, I think especially serious implications for our mental health, both in our 20s and beyond and even
大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听众，老听众，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。非常高兴你能回来收听新的一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析二字头年龄段的心理。在开始之前，先给出一个简短的内容预警：本期节目确实会深入探讨一些关于减肥、增重、外貌和饮食失调的话题。所以，请花一点时间考虑一下，你目前是否处于一个健康的心理状态、是否拥有积极的心态来收听这些内容。本期节目过几天、一周或几个月后依然会在这里，所以当时间合适、状态更好时，你随时可以回来听。让我们开始吧。今天我们要聊一个相当脆弱的话题，我认为它对我们的心理健康有着尤其严重的影响，无论是在20多岁时、之后甚至
before. And it can also just be such a present and overwhelming shadow in our lives. Our thoughts, our feelings, our opinions about our body do have this incredible capacity to really influence every other area of our daily life, of our existence, of our values, of our relationships. And yet we really do tend to kind of keep it out of the light of day. We really avoid discussing this openly because I think of, you know, well, shame and how hard it is to come out and say, you know, at the moment I really dislike my body, I really hate some part of me or I'm fixated on my appearance and I don't know how to stop it. I think it's also what it comes down to is embarrassment as well as shame.
之前。它也可能成为我们生活中一种无时无刻不在且令人窒息的阴影。我们对身体的想法、感受和看法，确实拥有如此惊人的力量，能够真正影响我们日常生活、生存状态、价值观和人际关系的每一个其他领域。然而，我们确实倾向于将它深藏不露，避而不谈。我们真的在回避公开讨论这个话题，因为我认为，你知道，这关乎羞耻感，要开口说出“此刻我真的很讨厌我的身体，我真的很讨厌自己的某些部分，或者我满脑子都是对外貌的执念，却不知道该如何停止”是多么困难。我认为归根结底，除了羞耻感，还有尴尬。
The sense that caring this much about your looks is somehow, you know, vapid or vain, when actually it goes so much deeper than what other people might want to label it. It is and can be very disordered, a very disordered pattern of thinking. And beyond that, something that is hugely and largely beyond our control. I've come to realize the more I also choose to speak more openly about this experience, how many of us are struggling with some form of negative and harsh thinking about our bodies, about our weight, about our appearance. But you wouldn't think that, given how much we have trained ourselves and society has trained us to be silent about it. Beyond that, it hasn't just trained us to be silent. it's also trained us to view and treat our body like it is a constant work in progress
那种认为如此在乎外表在某种程度上是肤浅或虚荣的感觉，而实际上，它要比其他人可能贴上的标签深刻得多。它确实可以并且已经成为一种非常失调的思维模式。不仅如此，它还在很大程度上超出了我们的控制范围。我逐渐意识到，当我选择更公开地谈论这段经历时，有多少人也在与某种形式的对身体、体重和外貌的负面及严苛想法作斗争。但鉴于我们自己以及社会已经训练我们对此保持沉默，你绝不会想到这一点。不仅如此，它不仅训练我们保持沉默，还训练我们将身体视为一个需要不断改造的项目
rather than something that we can just be satisfied with as it is. So consider this your safe space. We're going to discuss everything to do with this today, specifically the topic of body dysmorphia and what that actually means. I think we hear a lot of people talk about how, you know, they are dissatisfied with their appearance, with their weight. is that always body dysmorphia or can we just have symptoms without a diagnosable condition? The other point that people mention is how it's really difficult to even be able to tell what we look like,
而不是一个我们可以直接对其感到满意的现状。所以，请把这里当成你的安全空间。今天我们将讨论与此相关的一切，特别是身体变形障碍这个话题，以及它究竟意味着什么。我想我们经常听到有人说，你知道，他们对自己的外貌、体重感到不满意。这总是身体变形障碍吗？还是说我们只是有一些症状，却尚未达到可诊断的程度？人们提到的另一个问题是，我们甚至很难弄清楚自己到底长什么样，
how a lot of us are really struggling with just a genuine acknowledgement of our appearance and how other people see us. Is that body dysmorphia or is that something else? What is the actual, I would say, pathology and criteria behind BDD? body dysmorphic disorder. So we're going to discuss all of that, including the origins of this condition, what makes us more susceptible,
我们中的许多人都在苦恼于如何真正客观地认可自己的外貌以及别人是如何看待我们的。这到底是身体变形障碍，还是别的什么？我想说的是，BDD（躯体变形障碍）背后的真正病理和诊断标准究竟是什么？所以我们将讨论所有这一切，包括这种状况的根源、是什么让我们更容易受到影响，
including the impact of toxic gym and diet culture, how it manifests the impact, but also some stories from you guys, the listeners, who were really vulnerable and open about their personal experiences. And I also just want to talk more generally about what it means to really dislike your body without having BDD.
包括有毒的健身和饮食文化的影响、它的表现形式、带来的影响，还有来自你们这些听众的一些故事，他们非常坦诚和公开地分享了个人经历。我还想更广泛地谈谈，在没有患上BDD的情况下，真正讨厌自己的身体意味着什么。
and why that is becoming increasingly more common and what we can actually do about it. What are ways of interrupting this really negative belief system that our appearance is really at the core of our worth or matters more than it does? So we have so much to talk about, so much research, so much science, and of course, so much psychology. So without further ado, let us get into it. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
以及为什么这种情况正变得越来越普遍，我们又能对此做些什么。有哪些方法可以打破这种消极的信念系统——即我们的外貌是决定我们价值的核心，或者它比实际情况更重要？所以我们有太多的话题要聊，有那么多的研究、科学，当然，还有那么多的心理学。废话不多说，让我们切入正题。2%。这就是当电梯和自动扶梯同时存在时，选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，培养心理韧性、保持健康以及建立适应力的科学。
I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inundated. inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships,
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，超越那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾经坚信种子油是天然具有炎症性的。我们大错特错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
你就会在经历风雨后，变成一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。欢迎收听《2%》。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《2%》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小肯姆胸部的场景吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小肯姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。包括最近一期邀请了马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you're just so you. y'all know. I mean, at this point, this is the second episode where we've discussed Craig, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, you're finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever
大谈80年代的可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊可卡因，但为了让你们清楚，为了让大家知道。我的意思是，此时此刻，这是我们第二次讨论可卡因了，所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还讨论了艾滋病。所以，你快把那句话说完了。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。欢迎在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听
you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
你的播客。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师科尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时候，当我们追求某个目标时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns. Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth,
我们太沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却依然在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯。达斯顿·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要，
or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
还是说你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。而且这是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你能真正发自内心地做一个好人。加入我，科尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，我们一起就疗愈、成长、父职、压力和人生目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会暴露出她证词中的明显矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法庭之战以证明真相。埃伦女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测报告。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregal, Westby and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·韦斯特比和迈克尔·马兰蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Body dysmorphia is one of those conditions that I think we've all heard about, which is definitely and largely misunderstood. So to start off with, I just want to get our kind of basics down pat, what actually is BDD. So BDD, body dysmorphic disorder, is a mental health condition. and it's a lot more than feeling occasionally negative about your body.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终将面临法律制裁。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。欢迎在IHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或各大播客平台收听《Love Trapped》播客。身体变形障碍是我们都听说过的一种疾病，我认为它绝对在很大程度上被误解了。所以首先，我只想让我们对基础知识有个清晰的了解，究竟什么是BDD。
It is an entire pattern, roundabout cycle, maze, inescapable maze of negative emotions, negative perceptions and negative feelings that are all directed towards your appearance. And what it really involves is an obsessive focus and shame and anxiety around some perceived flaw in our appearance. this often very small feature of us. It could be, you know, some feature of our face, our physique, muscle mass, our skin, a combination of all of those things, our weight, our height. And this small feature becomes a preoccupation, regardless of whether it is real or imagined,
它是一整套模式、绕来绕去的循环、迷宫，一个无法逃脱的负面情绪、负面认知和负面感受的迷宫，所有这些都指向你的外貌。它真正涉及的是对我们外貌中某种感知到的缺陷的强迫性关注、羞耻感和焦虑。这个缺陷通常是我们身上非常小的特征。它可能是，你知道的，我们脸部的某个特征、体形、肌肉量、我们的皮肤，所有这些因素的结合，我们的体重，我们的身高。而这个小特征变成了一种执念，无论它是真实的还是想象出来的，
no matter how small it is. So when I say real or imagined, I mean that this thing that we really dislike about ourselves, you know, it could be so tiny and abasurable. obscure that no one else would ever notice it. But for us, it feels like a huge part of who we are. It feels like we exist in the world and as we are existing, this huge spotlight is highlighting to ourselves and everybody around us this feature that we really don't like. Even when others say that we look amazing, they compliment us. They say we look lovely. They reassure us that no one is noticing this floor that we are focused on, we can't believe them. There is a part of us that is
无论它是多么微小。所以当我说是真实存在的还是想象出来的时，我的意思是，我们身上这个让我们非常讨厌的特点，你知道的，它可能非常微不足道且难以察觉，以至于其他人永远不会注意到它。但对我们来说，它感觉像是我们是谁的很大一部分。我们感觉自己活在这个世界上，而在我们活着的同时，这个巨大的聚光灯正在向我们自己和周围的每个人突显出这个我们真的很讨厌的特征。即使别人说我们看起来很棒，他们赞美我们。他们说我们看起来很可爱。他们向我们保证，没有人注意到我们所关注的这个缺点，但我们无法相信他们。我们内心深处有一个部分
quite honestly delusional and constantly tells us that all these other people must be lying. They just can't see it. They must be blind in some way. And so we continue to have this hyper focus on this floor and we normally resort to repetitive behaviours in order to kind of self-soothe or regain some control over this aspect of our appearance that is causing mental tension. So these behaviours are things like always checking ourselves in the mirror, constant mirror checking, constant grooming and touching or skin picking, only choosing clothes that will hide this feature or part of yourself. So these are actually called BDD safety behaviours and they're one step above avoidance whereby they make us feel like we have control over what part of us is being made
坦白说，它充满了妄想，并不断告诉我们，所有这些其他人一定都在撒谎。他们就是看不到。他们一定在某种程度上是盲目的。因此，我们继续对这个缺点保持高度关注，并且我们通常会求助于重复的行为，以便某种程度上自我安慰，或者重新获得对我们外表这方面的某种控制，而这种外表正在引起精神紧张。因此，这些行为包括像总是在镜子里检查自己，不断照镜子，不断修饰和触摸或抠皮肤，只选择能隐藏这个特征或你身体某一部分的衣服。所以这些实际上被称为BDD安全行为，它们比回避高出一层，使我们觉得自己能够控制我们身体的哪一部分被制造
visible to others and therefore we can control the judgments that we assume people are making about us based on this feature. So it's not just that we have a fixation on this floor. It's not just that we have this personal spotlight. It's also that in order to be meeting the criteria of BDD, you have to become obsessed with how you can fix it. In our minds, if the floor was to disappear or suddenly go away, so would all of our mental distress. And so we are always searching or coming up with a plan to erase this part of us, whether that is through excessive exercise, intense skincare routines, or cosmetic surgery. So cosmetic surgery has a really important kind of place in this disdise.
对其他人来说是可见的，因此我们可以控制我们认为人们根据这个特征对我们做出的判断。所以，这不仅仅是我们对这个缺点有执念。这不仅仅是我们有这个个人的聚光灯。这也是为了符合BDD的标准，你必须痴迷于如何解决它。在我们的脑海里，如果这个缺点消失了或突然不见了，我们所有的精神痛苦也会随之消失。因此，我们一直在寻找或想出一个计划来抹去我们的这一部分，无论是通过过度的运动、强烈的护肤程序，还是整容手术。所以整容手术在这类疾病中占据了非常重要的一种地位。
now that I've kind of brought it up, what I found was really interesting when I was really digging into this research is that whilst only about, I would say, three to five percent of the general population has BDD, and that's even like quite a generous statistic. It's probably sitting at around 3.5 amongst people who pursue cosmetic interventions, not just surgery, but fillers, injections, non-invasive procedures. That prevalence. of BDD in that population rises to almost 25%. So depending on how you feel about cosmetic surgery, you may think that this could provide some relief to people with BDD.
现在既然我已经提到了这一点，当我深入研究这项研究时，我发现非常有趣的是，虽然我可以说只有大约百分之三到五的普通人口患有BDD，这甚至是一个相当慷慨的统计数据。在追求整容干预的人群中，这个比例可能在3.5左右，这里不仅指手术，还包括填充剂、注射、非侵入性手术。这种流行程度。BDD在这一人群中的比例上升到了近25%。因此，根据你对整容手术的看法，你可能会认为这可以为患有BDD的人提供一些缓解。
It's almost like a treatment, right? You know, if they're experiencing so much shame associated with their appearance, here is this fix. But on the other hand, this is a multi-billion dollar industry that makes its money on exacerbating and preying on these insecurities and the purported ability to kind of fix them. We have to remember, BDD is a mental disorder, not a physical disorder. The problem is with cosmetic intervention is that it actually often makes people with body dysmorphic
这几乎就像一种治疗，对吧？你知道的，如果他们体验到与外表相关的如此多的羞耻感，这里就是这个解决方案。但另一方面，这是一个价值数十亿美元的行业，它通过加剧和利用这些不安全感以及所谓能够“修复”它们的能力来赚钱。我们必须记住，BDD是一种精神疾病，而不是身体疾病。整容干预的问题在于，它实际上往往会让患有躯体变形
disorder feel worse or actually just the same after the procedure. They may even become more preoccupied with the perceived flaw because it has just changed. It hasn't gone away. And they can seek further cosmetic procedures leading to at times an addiction. So something that really fascinated me about this kind of interaction between body dysmorphic disorder and cosmetic surgery is the study that said that, yes, a lot of people who pursue cosmetic surgery would actually meet the criteria for this mental condition. But more so, they are actually also the people that are most likely to take legal action against surgeons. Because even when the surgeon in their mind has fixed this floor, you know, it hasn't gone away just because it's, you know, physical form has changed. This feature of us is once again a preoccupation that it's coming from
障碍的人在手术后感觉更糟，或者实际上感觉和以前一样。他们甚至可能对这个感知到的缺点变得更加全神贯注，因为它刚刚发生了改变。它并没有消失。他们可能会寻求进一步的整容手术，有时会导致成瘾。所以，真正让我着迷的是躯体变形障碍和整容手术之间的这种互动，有一项研究说，是的，许多追求整容手术的人实际上符合这种精神状况的标准。但更重要的是，他们实际上也是最有可能对外科医生采取法律行动的人。因为即使在他们心目中外科医生已经修复了这个缺点，你知道的，它并没有因为它的，你知道的，物理形态发生了改变而消失。我们身上的这个特征再次成为了一种全神贯注的事情，它来自于
something that is kind of mentally disturbed or mentally, I don't like to say broken, mentally different is probably a better way. Mentally disordered, right? It's just not an accurate reflection of what we actually look like. It's not an accurate reflection of our physical form. So it doesn't actually matter if that feature of us changes. So obviously not everybody with BDD is going to to seek out cosmetic surgery, but I think it does really reveal to us how hard it is to control such a loud and persistent thoughts about our body and why it does seem that drastic measures will be the only solution to silence them. This is often why as well BDD is compared to parallel disorders like OCD and eating disorders. I feel like that one might have come to mind for you
某种精神上受到扰乱或精神上，我不喜欢说破碎，精神上不同可能是更好的方式。精神失常，对吧？它根本不是我们实际长相的准确反映。它不是我们身体形态的准确反映。所以，我们身上的那个特征是否改变其实并不重要。所以很明显，并不是每个患有BDD的人都会去寻求整容手术，但我觉得它确实向我们展示了，控制关于我们身体的如此响亮且持续的想法是多么困难，以及为什么看起来只有采取激烈的行动才是让它们安静下来的唯一解决方案。这也是为什么BDD经常被拿来与强迫症（OCD）和进食障碍等并行疾病进行比较。我觉得那个可能已经出现在你的脑海里了
almost immediately. And these disorders in particular have a high comorbidity with BDD. That means that often, not often, but, you know, it's not uncommon for people to have a dual diagnosis. So for these two things to be appearing at the same time, for somebody to have BDD and an eating disorder or OCD and BDD. So the comparison to OCD really emerges because of the excessive fixation, which results in compulsive behaviors, which really kind of.
几乎是立刻。这些疾病特别是与BDD有很高的共病率。这意味着通常，也不是经常，但是，你知道的，人们患有双重诊断并不罕见。也就是这两件事情同时出现，某人同时患有BDD和进食障碍，或者强迫症和BDD。因此，与强迫症的比较确实是因为过度执着而产生的，这会导致强迫行为，这真的有点像。
which really kind of follows a similar format to how OCD manifests. However, with body dysmorphia, it's really solely based on an obsession and a compulsion to do with appearance. So the link to eating disorders is also quite a common one. If someone is that disgusted, I would say almost tormented by their appearance. Sometimes this can really manifest in disordered eating habits, you know, wanting to control. this aspect of yourself through whatever behavior or means necessary. But it's also important to remember that a lot of people with BDD do actually just have quite normal eating patterns. Like, you can have BDD without abnormal eating. It's also interesting because people who are experiencing
这实际上有点类似于强迫症的表现形式。然而，对于躯体变形障碍，它真的完全基于与外表有关的强迫观念和强迫行为。因此，与进食障碍的联系也是相当普遍的。如果有人对此感到恶心，我可以说几乎被他们的外表折磨着。有时这真的会表现为失调的饮食习惯，你知道的，想要控制。通过任何必要的行为或手段来控制你自己的这一方面。但同样重要的是要记住，许多患有BDD的人实际上只是有相当正常的饮食模式。就像，你可以在没有异常饮食的情况下患有BDD。这也是很有趣的，因为人们正在经历
anorexia or binge eating disorder or bulimia, yes, they may find that this has resulted from initial feelings of like extreme dissatisfaction and fixation with some people. received flaw, but also another component of this is that sometimes there is, you know, behaviors like restricting food or excessive exercising or purging can also emerge simply from a place of control, not just bodily modification, which is why I think BDD is really deserving of its own separate diagnosis. All right, so let's talk about risk factors here. There are obviously some people who are a lot more susceptible to this than others like most mental health conditions. And when we talk about mental health conditions and we talk about who's at risk, the biggest thing
神经性厌食症、暴食症或贪食症，是的，他们可能会发现这源于最初的极度不满感以及对某些人的固定看法。感知的缺陷，但这一点的另一个组成部分是，有时确实存在，你知道的，限制食物或过度运动或催吐等行为也可能仅仅源于控制欲，而不仅仅是身体改造，这就是为什么我认为BDD确实值得拥有其单独的诊断。好吧，让我们来谈谈这里的风险因素。显然有些人在这一点上比其他人更容易受到影响，就像大多数心理健康状况一样。当我们谈论心理健康状况以及谁处于危险之中时，最重要的事情
it mostly comes down to or always comes back to in some sense is family history. If someone in your close or your immediate family has endured BDD, your chances go up quite a bit. this you know it comes down to genetic predisposition but also exposure and life experiences you know if that individual with BDD was a parent their own experience with this condition is going to influence how they raise you and how they parent you as much as they may try for it not to you know if this kind of condition goes untreated it does have the impact of bleeding into all these other aspects of our lives, including our relationships. So, for example, I heard from someone who spoke about how their mother was obsessed with slimness for all her life. She would endure these, like, drastic
它在某种意义上主要归结为或总是回归到家族史。如果你身边或直系亲属中有人忍受过BDD，你的几率会上升相当多。这你知道它归结为基因易感性，还有接触和生活经历，你知道的，如果那个患有BDD的个体是一位父母，他们自己对这种状况的经历将影响他们如何抚养你以及如何对你进行为人父母的教育，尽管他们可能尽量不去这样，你知道的，如果这种状况得不到治疗，它确实会产生蔓延到我们生活所有其他方面的冲击，包括我们的关系。例如，我听一个人的经历说，她的母亲一生都沉迷于纤瘦。她会忍受这些，比如激进的
diets. She got multiple surgeries in the pursuit of this small body, this small physique. She would always comment on her weight to others. She really never seemed happy, regardless of the results. So definitely meeting the criteria for BDD here. And as a child, this person's about how her mother really implanted a lot of those beliefs in her through the way that she, you know, controlled her as a parent. She would, you know, control her food, for example. She would choose flattering clothes and colors for her and tell her these are the colors that you should wear or you can't wear those things. They make you look fat. She was constantly, you know, commenting on her skin, especially as she hit puberty and developed acne. And this person said to me,
饮食。为了追求这种小巧的身体、纤细的体型，她做过多次手术。她总是对别人评论她的体重。无论结果如何，她似乎都从不快乐。所以这里绝对符合BDD的标准。作为一个孩子，这个人谈到了她的母亲如何通过她为人父母的方式控制她，将许多这些信念植入她的心中。例如，她会，你知道的，控制她的食物。她会为她挑选讨人喜欢的衣服和颜色，并告诉她这些是你应该穿的颜色，或者你不能穿那些东西。它们让你看起来很胖。她不断地，你知道的，评论她的皮肤，尤其是当她进入青春期并长了粉刺时。这个人对我说，
you know, two years ago, I got the same diagnosis that my mom had gotten. And sometimes I think how much of it was genetic and how much of it was environmental and was my, you know, the environment of my upbringing. Because in those situations, how are you meant to develop a healthy sense of self-esteem? How are you meant to detach your appearance from your self-worth? When that kind of preoccupation is being passed down to you by the person in your life that matters the most to you as a child, which is your caregiver. This kind of example, and I don't like to say example, this person's experience here, they're very much personal experience, really demonstrates to me as well how negative life experiences also play a really crucial role, especially experiences like
你知道的，两年前，我得到了和我妈妈一样的诊断。有时我想，其中有多少是基因决定的，多少是环境决定的，我的，你知道的，我长大的环境是怎样的。因为在这种情况下，你怎么能培养出健康的自尊感呢？你怎么能把你的外表从你的自我价值中剥离开来？当这种全神贯注被作为你童年中对你最重要的人，也就是你的照顾者，传递给你时。这种类型的例子，我不喜欢说是例子，这个人的经历，他们非常个人的经历，也真正向我展示了负面生活经验如何也起着真正关键的作用，特别是像
childhood bullying, like neglect, like teasing, like abuse. So I actually have a story about this that is from my own life that I've never really shared before on this show. You know, it never really came up. But it is one of my earliest and most lucid memories from childhood. It's also one of those moments that really goes to show how, you know, passing words can really leave quite a lifelong mark. So when I was around seven, six or seven years old. I used to always go to out of after school hours care. Like, I don't know if that's a thing everywhere in the world, but, you know, both my parents were working. And so I like stayed at the school a little bit longer with like other kids whose parents were also working or also had
童年欺凌、忽视、取笑、虐待。所以实际上我有一个关于这的故事，它来自我自己的生活，我以前从未在这个节目中真正分享过。你知道的，它从来没有真正出现过。但它是我童年时期最早、最清醒的记忆之一。这也是那些真正表明，你知道的，随口说出的话如何真正留下终生印记的时刻之一。所以当我大约七岁，六七岁的时候。我过去常常去课后托管班。就像，我不知道这在世界各地是不是一件普遍的事情，但是，你知道的，我的父母都在工作。所以我有点像在学校多待了一会儿，和那些父母也在工作或也有其他事情要做的其他孩子在一起。
things to do. And we were watching this movie with a bunch of other kids called the little princess. And this boy turns to me and he goes, you know, you look, you would look just like her if you weren't so fat. I have never been able to shake those words. Even till this day, they have left such an imprint on me. It was like the first time that I ever felt shame about my body. And I think when I was a teenager, now as an adult, my whole life, my weight has been a point of fixation for me. There has never been a period of my life where I've been satisfied with how I look or how my way, how I feel in my body. And I often wonder whether that would have been different if that hadn't happened. Because it was almost like this new, you know, it was almost like that was the beginning.
事情要做。我们和其他一群孩子在看一部电影，叫《小公主》。这个男孩转向我，他说，你知道的，你看起来，如果你没有那么胖，你看起来就会和她一模一样。我从来没有能够摆脱这些话。直到今天，它们在我的身上留下了如此深刻的印记。这就像我第一次对自己的身体感到羞耻。我想当我还是个青少年时，现在作为成年人，我整的一生中，我的体重一直是我全神贯注的焦点。在我生命的任何时期，我都从未对自己的外表、我的体重以及我在自己身体里的感觉感到满意。我常常想，如果那件事没有发生，这一切会不会有所不同。因为这几乎就像这个新的，你知道的，这几乎就像那是开始。
Like I became conscious of everything that I could change that I didn't like about myself and the fact that people could observe these things that I didn't like about myself and could make judgments or mean comments to me about my appearance and it mattered. It's also really, really interesting to me how that continues to come up as a problem for me in my life. I posted like this random video on my Instagram a few weeks ago. If you follow me over there, I think you'll know which one it is. And it reached an audience that I basically like didn't intend it to. Like it went semi-viral. And the audience was, you know, men in their like 30s and 40s who didn't, you didn't agree with what I was saying. And as always goes with those situations if like a middle-aged man
就像我开始意识到我可以改变的、我不喜欢自己的所有事情，以及人们可以观察到这些我不喜欢自己的事情，并且可以对我外表做出判断或刻薄的评论，而这很重要。这也让我感到非常非常有趣的是，这如何继续成为我生活中的一个问题。几周前我在我的Instagram上发布了这个随机的视频。如果你在那里关注我，我想你会知道是哪一个。它触及了一个我基本上没有打算让它触及的受众。就像它半病毒式传播了一样。而受众是，你知道的，三十多岁和四十多岁的男性，他们不同意我所说的话。正如在这种情况下总是会发生的那样，如果一个中年男人
doesn't agree with what you're saying. The first thing they're going to resort to doing is making a comment about your weight or your appearance. And oh my gosh, did I not get hundreds of them? And they were awful. And the only thing I could think of was, oh my God, this is just like this all over again. It brought me right back to that version of me who was first really made aware that her body wasn't just there to climb and to run and to play and to giggle and to eat yummy foods. It was there to be judged. Those early life experiences might seem very far in the past, but they definitely linger,
不同意你所说的话。他们首先要求做的事情就是对你的体重或外表发表评论。哦，天哪，我难道没有收到数百条这样的评论吗？而且它们太糟糕了。我能想到的唯一一件事就是，哦天哪，这简直就像是这一切的重演。它把我直接带回了那个版本的自己，她最初真正意识到她的身体不仅仅是为了攀爬、奔跑、玩耍、咯咯笑和吃美味的食物。它是为了被评判。那些早期的生活经历可能看起来在遥远的过去，但它们绝对挥之不去，
especially since BDD typically starts, you know, in our early teen years when everything is so formative, but also when those childhood experiences and memories are a lot more fresh and we are a lot more impressionable. So there are some other risk factors, including personality traits like perfectionism. if we are of course preoccupied with being flawless in every other area of our life, of course our appearance is going to come into that.
特别是自从BDD通常开始于，你知道的，在我们十几岁出头的时期，那时一切都具有塑造性，但也是那些童年的经历和记忆要新鲜得多，而我们也更容易受到影响的时候。所以还有一些其他的风险因素，包括像完美主义这样的性格特征。如果我们当然全神贯注于在我们生活的其他所有领域都做到完美无瑕，我们的外表当然也会卷入其中。
You know, the existence of even a tiny perceived floor, a bad skin day, stretch marks, a facial feature that can really disrupt our whole identity and be quite distressing. I will say something that is not a factor here is gender. So with eating disorders, for example, there is, you know, typically a much high, prevalence amongst women. It's normally around three times the rates that we would see in men for things like anorexia and bulimia. But for BDD, men and women, people of all genders are influenced the same. It just expresses itself quite differently. One area that this is really evident to me is when it comes to weight. Women typically want to be thinner, whereas men want more muscle. They're
你知道的，甚至存在一个微小的感知缺陷、糟糕的皮肤状况、妊娠纹、一个真正会扰乱我们整个身份并相当痛苦的面部特征。我要说这里的一个非决定性因素是性别。例如，对于进食障碍，你知道的，通常在女性中普遍率要高得多。对于厌食症和贪食症等情况，它通常是我们在男性中看到的比率的三倍左右。但对于BDD，男性和女性，所有性别的人受到的影响都是一样的。它只是表现得截然不同。这对我来说真正明显的一个领域是在体重方面。女性通常想要更瘦，而男性想要更多肌肉。他们
preoccupied with gaining weight. Obviously this isn't always the case, but I do think that it's a distinction that we can really see when we just look around ourselves, when we just compare what our male friends versus our female friends complain about when it comes to their size. So in the DSM, there is even a specifier around this particular kind of BDD that results from muscle dysmorphia, whereby somebody is really engrossed with the idea that their body build is too small. They are not muscular enough to be seen as, I don't know, manly or to be seen as big enough or worthy enough or like strong enough, whatever it is. This in my mind can also be really attributed to, I would say, a rise in toxic gym culture and this idea of big
全神贯注于增加体重。显然这并不总是这样，但我确实认为这是一个我们可以通过环顾四周真正看到的区别，当我们只是比较我们的男性朋友和女性朋友在他们的体型方面抱怨什么时。所以在《精神疾病诊断与统计手册》（DSM）中，甚至有一个关于这种由肌肉变形障碍导致的特定类型BDD的说明符，即某人全神贯注于这样一种想法，即他们的体格太小了。他们不够肌肉发达，不能被视为，我不知道，有男子气概，或者被视为足够大，或者足够有价值，或者足够强壮，无论它是什么。在我看来，这也真正归因于，我想说，有毒健身文化的兴起和这种盛大的想法
erectia. Now, this is a term that I learned from a recent article by The Guardian. And they talk about like how, you know, we all know what anorexia is. This is a play on word. And, and anorexia is typically associated with the pursuit of smallness and thinness, whereas bigorexia is this pursuit of being as huge as possible. And in this article, they spoke to some, you know, guys and some women as well, but mainly men about the lengths that they are willing to go to to achieve this. And how, no matter how many people say, wow, like, you are so huge, you're massive. Like, every time they look in the mirror, they do not see that.
勃起（注：此处原文为bigorexia的谐音误读，指肌肉迪斯莫菲亚/肌肉痴迷症，译文保持语境即可）。现在，这是我从《卫报》最近的一篇文章中学到的一个词。他们谈到了像，你知道的，我们都知道什么是厌食症。这是一个双关语。而且，厌食症通常与追求小巧和纤瘦有关，而大体型症（bigorexia）则是追求尽可能庞大的追求。在这篇文章中，他们采访了一些，你知道的，一些男士，也有一些女性，但主要是男性，关于他们愿意为实现这一目标付出多大的努力。以及，不管有多少人说，哇，就像，你太庞大了，你太巨大了。就像，每次他们照镜子时，他们都看不到这一点。
they see themselves as tiny. And this one man in this article was talking about how he would like eat. The only thing he would eat would be like chicken breasts and protein sources. And he was like I looked amazing. Like in my mind, I looked so huge. But I was so unhealthy and like his kidneys started failing and his liver started failing. And I think that that really comes down to this crucial point, which is that this obsession with a muscular body is largely ignored because it's seen as healthy
他们认为自己很微小。这篇文章中的这个男人谈到了他将如何进食。他唯一会吃的东西就是鸡胸肉和蛋白质来源。他说我看起来棒极了。就像在我的脑海里，我看起来太庞大了。但我很不健康，比如他的肾脏开始衰竭，肝脏开始衰竭。我认为这确实归结为这个关键点，即这种对肌肉发达身体的痴迷在很大程度上被忽视了，因为它被视为健康
or a worthwhile bodily pursuit because, you know, what's unhealthy about strength and what's unhealthy about spending time in the gym? What's unhealthy with fueling your body in this optimal way? What's unhealthy about protein? And I think a lot of people experiencing this, witnessing this would be quick to highlight how easy it is for this to tip. into very unhealthy and maladaptive terrain, how this is just another version of an unrealistic or an extreme expectation for our body image that is promoted by certain in-groups
或者是一个值得的身体追求，因为，你知道的，力量有什么不健康的，花时间在健身房有什么不健康的？以这种最佳方式为身体补充能量有什么不健康的？蛋白质有什么不健康的？我认为许多经历这一点、目睹这一点的人会很快指出，这很容易演变成非常不健康和适应不良的领域，这只是我们的身体形象的不切实际或极端期望的另一种版本，而这种期望是由某些内群体所推广的
and certain cultures and certain aspects of society. So this distinction, this general distinction is, I think, between weight loss and weight gain for different genders, is essentially a reflection of what society expects from men and women. You know, the beauty ideals that each, gender is very much forced to endure. And we can't ignore that component, the influence of our social conditioning and how we have been taught to hate our bodies, not instinctually, but through external influence. So BDD, I think is what I would call a modern day disorder, because it really
以及某些文化和社会某些方面。因此，这种区别，这种普遍的区别，我认为，是不同性别在减肥和增重之间的区别，本质上反映了社会对男女的期望。你知道的，每个性别都被迫承受的美丽理想。我们不能忽视那个组成部分，我们的社会条件反射的影响，以及我们是如何被教导去憎恨我们的身体的，不是本能地，而是通过外部影响。所以BDD，我认为这是我会称之为现代疾病的东西，因为它确实
has arisen mainly in the last 100 years, probably even 20 to 50 years specifically. And it's really emerged as some researchers would say from the fact that we now have more comparison points than ever to judge ourselves based on. And we are increasingly being exposed to this messaging around what we should look like and what is not desirable. This is because things like TV, advertising, social media, they have made us more aware of the social norms around attraction and what society sees as beautiful or not. Secondly, they have exposed us to what other people look like, meaning, of course, more opportunities to come up short and compare. And finally, you know, the media users looks and appearance as something through which they can
主要在过去100年中出现，可能特别是在最近20到50年中。正如一些研究人员所说，它的出现确实是因为我们现在拥有比以往任何时候都多的比较点来评判自己。我们越来越多地接触到关于我们应该长什么样以及什么是不理想的信息。这是因为电视、广告、社交媒体等事物让我们更加意识到关于吸引力的社会规范，以及社会认为什么是美丽或不美丽。其次，它们让我们接触到其他人长什么样，这意味着，当然，有更多机会让自己相形见绌并进行比较。最后，你知道的，媒体利用外貌和外表作为一种可以通过其来进行的
influence and sell us things. And so, let's be honest, they benefit from us not feeling great. They benefit from us seeing a beautiful person on TV and wanting whatever skin care product that they're using or seeing, you know, a huge, huge guy on some superhero movie and admiring not just this plot line and this narrative around him being a hero, but the fact that he looks so great. And the fact that we could copy his workout routine and the fact that he is like this really jacked, cool guy.
影响并向我们推销东西。说实话，它们从我们感觉不太好中获益。它们从我们在电视上看到一个美女，就想买她用的某种护肤品中获益；或者看到某个超级英雄电影里身材魁梧的壮汉，不仅赞叹他的剧情和英雄叙事，还赞叹他那绝佳的身材。我们幻想着复制他的健身计划，觉得他是个超级强壮、酷炫的家伙。
And the sociocultural theory of self-esteem would tell you that the message is given to us by the media about the importance of appearance and what is hot and what is attractive and what looks good, they are so easily internalized by us as individuals, and they also so easily influence how we treat ourselves, our standards, our habits, and our behaviors. I think as we feel more pressure to conform with that, we become more aware once again of the aspects of ourselves that we feel will be judged based on prevailing norms of attraction.
而自尊的社会文化理论会告诉你，媒体向我们传递的关于外表重要性、什么是性感、什么是迷人、什么是好看的信息，作为个体，我们极其容易将这些内化。它们同样极其容易影响我们对待自己的方式、我们的标准、习惯以及行为。我认为，当我们感受到更多去顺应这种潮流的压力时，我们就会再次更加意识到自己身上那些根据主流审美标准会被评判的方面。
If I am not thin, does that mean I will be unhappy? If I am not bigger, if I don't fix my nose, if I don't fix my skin, does that mean that I will never find love? Will they consider me for this job if my hair is thinning? If I'm too frail, if whatever, my teeth aren't straight. and all of it comes back to this idea, this irrational belief that the secret to happiness is our appearance. I want to share another person's experience here because I think they articulated it so well in a much better way than I ever could. I've struggled with body dysmorphia and eating disorders since I was 12.
如果我不够瘦，是不是意味着我不会快乐？如果我不够高大，如果不去整容，不改善皮肤，是不是意味着我永远也找不到真爱？如果我的头发在变稀疏，他们还会考虑录用这这份工作吗？如果我太虚弱，或者牙齿长得不够整齐……这一切都归结于这样一个观点，即这种不理性的信念：快乐的秘诀在于我们的外表。在这里我想分享另一个人的经历，因为我觉得她表达得太好了，比我所能做到的要好得多。我从12岁起就一直在跟身体变形恐惧症（body dysmorphia）和饮食失调做斗争。
I'm 22 now. Last year I started recovery and treatment after being at my lowest with my symptoms, so I had the urge of seeking help. it's been a tough journey and very difficult to accept the diagnosis. The mind-blowing thing is that almost my entire adolescence, and early adult years, I thought life was about my weight, appearance, and body composition. And I made it till now, just like that, fitting so perfectly into society, and no one noticed that something was going on. What I'd like to emphasise is that just because weight loss and obsession with appearance
我现在22岁。去年，在症状达到最低谷后，我开始了康复和治疗，所以我有了寻求帮助的冲动。这是一段艰难的旅程，要接受这个诊断也非常困难。最让人震惊的是，在我的整个青春期和成年早期，我都以为生活就是关于体重、外表和身体成分的。我就这样一路走到了现在，完美地融入了社会，竟然没有人发现有什么不对劲。我想强调的是，仅仅因为减脂瘦身和对外表的执念
is culturally normalized in our society, doesn't mean that it is healthy or even pleasurable at all. I've been in this mental prison for years, losing time, missing experiences, people that I will never regain. I really hope that we could move towards a more inclusive society in terms of body norms, to not feel like the only way to fit in is through a stereotype of beauty that is unachievable.
在我们的社会中被文化规范化了，并不意味着它是健康的，甚至一点也不快乐。我被困在这个精神监狱里好几年，失去了时间，错过了永远无法找回的经历和人。我真的希望我们能在身体标准方面走向一个更具包容性的社会，不再让人觉得融入集体的唯一途径是通过那种无法实现的审美刻板印象。
Unachievable. I love that this individual, firstly thank you so much for sharing and it's that was like kind of emotional when I first read that but secondly I like that you finished on that because so many of our you know of the examples that fuel our body dysmorphia are the 1% are due to like crazy amazing genetics are due to something that we could never change and at times or even due to somebody who themselves has body dysmorphia and who is you know undergoing some you know crazy surgery. and crazy efforts to fix the part of themselves that we are sitting back and admiring.
无法实现。我太喜欢这段话了，首先非常感谢分享，我第一次读到时甚至有点感触。但其次，我很高兴你以这个话题结束，因为我们身上很多助长身体变形恐惧症的例子——那1%的人——是由于极其惊人的基因，是由于我们永远无法改变的东西。有时甚至是因为那些本身就患有身体变形恐惧症、正在经历某些疯狂手术的人，他们付出了疯狂的努力去修复我们坐在台下赞叹的他们身上的某个部位。
So I really think that it is such a weird mess around where if everybody's experiencing this, the person that we are probably comparing ourselves to is probably looking at us or looking at somebody else and wanting what they have as well. So, you know, the norm is constantly evolving and yet we're constantly chasing the sense of, again, that appearance equals happiness. All right, we're going to take a short break, but when we come back, I want to discuss whether body dysmorphia is more prevalent than we think, but also how we can kind of move through some of the stress, dissatisfaction, worry, anxiety around our appearance.
所以我真的觉得这是一个非常奇怪的混乱局面：如果每个人都在经历这种心态，那么我们可能在比较的对象，或许也在看着我们或其他人，渴望着对方拥有的东西。所以你知道，规范在不断演变，然而我们却在不断追逐那种再次认为“外表等于快乐”的感觉。好了，我们要休息一下，但回来后，我想讨论一下身体变形恐惧症是否比我们想象的更为普遍，以及我们如何才能摆脱围绕外表的压力、不满、担忧和焦虑。
Stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry.
请继续收听。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等人对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world, are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush
这就是《2%》。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。还记得戴安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什到底
got to do a little kill. Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes.
和小金有什么关系。好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期节目中，马马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）大谈80年代的快克可卡因。澄清一下，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都能聊快克，但只是想让你们知道。我是说，马克，这是我们讨论快克的第二集了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在甚至把艾滋病也摆到台面上了。谢谢你把话说完。是的。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade. of my own experience in the mental health field
我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的一年之一。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将带来我过去十年中
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
在心理健康领域的亲身经验，以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们甚至不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person? because you're afraid. Because that's two different intentions, bro.
因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross）。因为你觉得在这个世上做一个好人很重要。你是个好人吗？因为你感到害怕。因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。
Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app.
绝对是的。这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，让我们一起就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。
Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so much.
搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了他供词中明显的前后矛盾。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼之战，以证明真相。你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，所以……
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There is an important to see.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这里有一个重要的。
distinction here between BDD and having the occasional negative perception about our body. And it is an important one because I would go so far as to say that nearly every single one of us has something that they want to change about how we look, but we aren't really going to drastic measures to do that. You know, maybe that doesn't qualify us as having a mental health condition. However, I think just because it's not as intense as it is for people with body dysmorphia doesn't make hating your body easy. It is so difficult to wake up in a body that you increasingly do not like or find problem with because that is your home.
身体变形障碍（BDD）与对我们身体偶尔产生负面看法之间存在着重要区别。这是一个重要的区别，因为我要说的是，几乎我们每个人都有想要改变的外表，但我们并没有为此采取激烈的措施。你知道，也许这并不意味着我们有心理健康问题。然而，我认为，仅仅因为它不像身体变形障碍患者那样强烈，并不意味着讨厌自己的身体是一件轻松的事。在一个你日益不喜欢或觉得有问题的身体里醒来是极其艰难的，因为那是你的家。
You know, as the incredible Emma Thompson says, that is your vessel. There is no escaping that you will exist in this body and no one else is until the day that you die. So hating how you look and how you feel quickly evolves into hating yourself, almost instantly. because the two things, you know, yourself or your soul and your appearance, your body, they're very hard to separate. So I wanted to hear from you guys, the listeners around the world, around just how many of us are experiencing this kind of daily dislike, how endemic it is.
正如不可思议的艾玛·汤普森（Emma Thompson）所说，那是你的容器。你无可逃避地将在这个身体里存在，直到你死去的的那一天，没有别人。所以，讨厌自己的外表和感受，很快就会演变成讨厌自己，几乎是不费吹灰之力。因为这两者——你知道的，你的自我或你的灵魂，与你的外表、你的身体——是非常难以分割的。所以我想听听你们这些世界各地的听众的意见，听听我们中有多少人正在经历这种日常的厌恶，这种现象有多么根深蒂固。
Because whilst I think we can all recognize the, you know, the universality of worry and dissatisfaction towards our appearance, I don't think we talk about it enough. And I think that having a general and a more like kind of, bird's eye view of just how many of us are going through this is quite comforting. So I kind of wanted to just siphon it down to the area of like weight loss because I feel like, or weight change, more like it, weight loss or weight change. Because I think that weight is something that most of us have a general insecurity about compared to more unique things about ourselves that are probably different between each of us. You know, it's kind of hard to talk about like, oh, would you want
因为虽然我认为我们都能认识到，大家对自己的外表都有着普遍的担忧和不满，但我认为我们对此讨论得还不够。而且，对我们中有多少人正在经历这一切有一个总体、更宏观的鸟瞰视角，其实是相当令人宽慰的。所以我只想把话题缩小到减重这个领域，因为我觉得，或者说是体重变化，更确切地说是减重或体重变化。因为我认为体重是大多数人普遍感到不安全感的事情，相比之下，我们每个人之间可能各不相同的更独特的特质。你知道，这很难讨论，比如，哦，你想
to change that unique scar? Or would you want to change that? Do you want a nose job? Like when people you know that's yeah big insecurity but not as prominent as weight is for all of us so you know it's kind of sad to say it but weight dissatisfaction is a bit of a human equalizer that's why i chose it so out of almost two thousand of you 70% of you said that in the past year you had thought about losing weight nearly every month and for those of you who said every month shockingly it was like 47% of that faction who said that you thought about it every day. Every day, some nearly 50% of you said every day that weight loss is on your mind, clouding your thoughts and your judgment.
改变那个独特的疤痕吗？或者你想改变那个？你想做隆鼻手术吗？当人们知道那是巨大的不安全感，但对我们所有人来说，它没有体重那么突出。所以，你知道，说这话有点难过，但对体重的不满有点像人类的“均等器”，这就是我选择它的原因。因此，在近两千名参与者中，有70%的人表示，在过去的一年里，他们几乎每个月都在考虑减肥。而对于那些说“每个月”的人，令人震惊的是，其中约有47%的人表示他们每天都在想这件事。每天，大约50%的人说他们每天都在想减肥，它占据着你的脑海，蒙蔽了你的思绪和判断力。
I want you to like genuinely think about this for a second. Is there any other worry or insecurity that we all share as much as that one? You know, as we are all going about our daily lives, we each have our own unique set of problems. we each have, you know, work deadlines, we each have relationship issues, we each have small anxieties, small to do-lis. And the one thing that seems to, you know, bind us all together is that in this small reality, that is our own reality, all of us are sharing this collective thought that we don't like
我希望你们真正认真地思考一秒钟。还有什么其他的担忧或不安全感是像这一样被我们所有人共同分担的吗？你知道，在我们进行日常生活时，我们每个人都有自己独特的问题集合。我们每个人都有工作截止日期，我们每个人都有人际关系问题，我们每个人都有小焦虑、小待办事项。而唯一似乎能把我们所有人紧密联系在一起的事情是，在这样一个属于我们自己的微小现实中，我们所有人都在共同分担着一个想法：我们不喜欢
how we look and that we want to lose weight. Like I was thinking about this the other day when I was on the train and I was looking around, it was like a pack train and I was like, how many people here right now have thought, about dieting today. How many people on this train have, you know, put on their jeans in the morning and been like, oh gosh, I really probably should lose a few. Like, and that's just crazy to me because you would look at all these people and, you know, if the statistics that I got from you guys are saying it, that's like 50% of those people on that train have thought about it that day. And yet I wouldn't have been able to tell you that that's what they were thinking. And yet I would
自己的外表，并且我们想要减肥。就像我前几天在火车上时想的那样，我环顾四周，那是一辆挤满人的列车，我在想：这里有多少人今天想过减肥。这列车上有多少人，早上穿上牛仔裤时会想：“哦天哪，我大概真的得减掉几斤了。”这对我来说太疯狂了，因为你会看着所有人，而且，如果我从你们那里得到的统计数据说明了一切，那意味着那列车上大约有50%的人那天都想过这事。然而我却看不出他们脑子里在想这些。然而我却
thought that I would be the only one because our own lives just feels so unique and so isolated. Beyond that, the other interesting question I asked you guys was whether you think that weight loss or a change in your size weight gain for some people would make you happier. And 67% of you said yes. Is there any other factor in our life in which two thirds of us would put our hands up and say, if that changed, I would be happier. Maybe like winning a million dollars. Maybe like finding the love of your life.
以为只有我一个人是这样，因为我们自己的生活感觉是如此独特和孤立。除此之外，我问大家的另一个有趣问题是，你是否认为减肥或体型改变（对某些人来说是增重）会让你更快乐。67%的人回答是。在我们生活中，还有哪个因素能让三分之二的人举手说：如果这个改变了，我会更快乐？也许就像中了一百万美元。也许就像找到了你一生的挚爱。
But both of those things are like additions, right? Weight loss is this thing, this subtraction that we believe is suddenly going to like open a whole new world to us. It's suddenly going to eliminate so much, I guess, insecurity, so much like hate that we have for ourselves. And I think that right there is where the core problem in this lies. The problem is that we have these. delusions that take over that insidiously tell us that if we just looked like her, if we just
但这两件事都像是“加法”，对吧？而减肥则是这样一种东西，一种我们坚信会突然为我们打开一个全新世界的“减法”。它会突然消除如此之多的不安全感，消除如此之多我们对自己怀有的厌恶。我认为，这正是核心问题所在。问题在于，我们有着这些。妄想，它们不知不觉地控制了我们，潜移默化地告诉我们：如果我们长得像她那样，如果我们只是
you know, lost that last killer or fix this small thing, gain some more muscle, our whole life would change. And so until then, there's nothing else we can do. Until then, until this miracle occurs, until this thing is fixed, we just kind of have to endure a less than happy reality. this thinking which I think most commonly we don't even adopt by choice also causes us to very much intrinsically tie our value to our appearance and that is what influences our behaviours. If your worth, if my worth is only activated when I think I look good, when that is not the case, why let myself be seen? Why believe I am deserving of happiness? Why feel happy? And we spoke about this briefly before, but to return to an example of this that I find particularly compelling
你知道的，减掉最后几公斤，或者修复这个小地方，增加更多肌肉，我们的整个人生就会改变。所以在此之前，我们什么也做不了。直到那时，直到这个奇迹发生，直到这个毛病被修复，我们似乎只能忍受一种不太快乐的现实。这种思维——我认为我们大多数人甚至都不是出于选择而接受的——也会导致我们非常内在、非常紧密地将自己的价值与外表绑定在一起，而这正是影响我们行为的因素。如果你的价值，如果我的价值只有在我认为自己长得好看时才被激活，当情况并非如此时，为什么还要让自己被看到？为什么相信自己配得上快乐？为什么要感到快乐？我们之前简短地讨论过这一点，但回到一个让我觉得特别引人注目的例子
is the experience of thinking that we need to look a certain way before dating, that no one could possibly love us at this size or this shape or this composition. And so our appearance is like almost this thing that we need to sort out before putting ourselves out there because we kind of realize that when we like put ourselves out into the romantic world, something that we're going to be evaluated on is appearance. And so the problem is, is that we begin to firstly overestimate the likelihood that others are going to respond to our appearance in a negative way. Secondly, we underestimate our ability to cope if they did. You know, if somebody doesn't like what you look like, is that the end of the world? If you have this fixation on your appearance and this
那就是认为我们在约会前必须保持某种特定外表的想法——认为没有人会爱这样体型、身材或结构的我们。所以我们的外表几乎成了我们在把自己推向外界之前需要解决的一件事，因为我们隐约意识到，当我们把自己投入浪漫的世界时，我们要被评估的一项内容就是外表。所以问题在于，我们开始时：首先，高估了别人对我们的外表做出负面反应的可能性；其次，低估了如果我们真的遭遇这种反应时的承受能力。你知道，如果有人不喜欢你的外表，那是世界末日吗？如果你对自己的外表有这种执念，并且
sense that it's tied to your worth, then of course it's going to matter. But thirdly, we really tend to discount any information which kind of suggests that things are not going to go as bad as we predicted. You know, when we're dating, we overlook all the times that people did find us really attractive. We overlook all the times that we were complimented and we just continue to think that if we were to be seen, if we were to be perceived, we would not be loved. And that just really, really broke my heart to just like even consider, to even say just then. These negative and false beliefs really follow us into every corner of our lives. And the thing is, is that they are entirely incorrect.
觉得它与你的价值挂钩，那它当然会很重要。但第三点，我们真的很倾向于忽视任何暗示事情并不会像我们预期的那样糟糕的信息。你知道，当我们在约会时，我们会忽略所有人真正觉得我们很有吸引力的时刻；我们会忽略所有受到赞美的时刻；我们依然不断地认为，如果我们被看见、如果我们被感知，我们就不会被爱。仅仅是考虑一下、或者刚刚说出这句话，就已经让我心碎不已。这些消极且错误的信念真的跟随我们进入了生活的每一个角落。问题是，它们完全是错误的。
This idea that your appearance determines your worthiness of love, your worthiness of opportunity, of success of happiness is a false belief. And you know how I know that these beliefs are incorrect is because all the of us are thinking them and none of us think that they are true for anybody but ourselves. None of us would for a second believe that one of our friends, you know, is unworthy of love or dates or affection because, you know, they didn't get a nose job when they were 16. Not a single person listening to this would tell their friend to not go for a job until they'd lost a few kilos. You know, have you ever heard somebody look at their partner and say,
这种认为你的外表决定了你是否值得被爱、是否值得拥有机遇、是否值得获得成功和快乐的观点，是一个错误的信念。你知道我是怎么知道这些信念是错误的吗？因为我们所有人都这么想，但我们谁也不认为这些信念对除自己以外的任何其他人是真实的。我们没有一个人会哪怕一秒钟地相信，我们的某位朋友因为在16岁时没有去做隆鼻手术，就不值得拥有爱情、约会或柔情。没有一个听众会告诉自己的朋友，在瘦掉几斤之前不要去应聘工作。你知道，你可曾听到有人看着伴侣说：
Yeah, sorry, babe, you know, I'm not going to say I love you until you fix those freckles or until you like gain some more muscle. No, because that is ridiculous. When we say it out loud, when we say it in the context of somebody else, that is ridiculous. And let's be honest, it's also incredibly toxic and harsh and dangerous. We would never say that to somebody else. And that's like a major red flag. If somebody ever even suggested that, it would be like the end of that relationship.
“是的，对不起，宝贝，你知道的，在你消除那些雀斑或增加更多肌肉之前，我是不会说我爱你直到永远的。”不，因为这太荒谬了。当我们大声说出来时，当我们在别人的语境中说出这样的话时，这太荒谬了。老实说，这也是极其有毒、刻薄和危险的。我们绝不会对别人说这种话。这绝对是个超级大红旗（危险信号）。如果有人哪怕暗示了这一点，那这段关系也就差不多走到头了。
and yet we have no problem believing those things about ourselves, saying it to ourselves, you know, demolishing our self-esteem and self-worth, the way that we would never do to somebody that we loved. And you know what's even worse is that it doesn't even feel like it's in our control. You know, that internal voice, that inner critic that is so loud and it does so much harm is something that we never quite feel like is part of us, right? It feels like this external thing that is within us that pops up,
然而，我们却毫无保留地对自己相信这些事情，对自己说这些话，你知道的，摧毁我们的自尊和自我价值——而这种事我们对深爱的人是绝对做不出来的。你知道更糟糕的是什么吗？这甚至让人感觉不在我们的控制之中。你知道，那个内部声音、那个声音巨大且造成极大伤害的内在批评者，让我们觉得它永远不完全属于我们，对吧？它感觉就像是我们体内的某种外部实体突然冒出来，
that we didn't even consciously want to hate our body or hate our appearance today. And yet here we are doing it. So what's next? If we have accepted that this is something that we are dealing with that is holding us back, that is causing us social anxiety, causing us avoidance, causing us to hold off on life, what can we change? What can we actually do?
而我们甚至没有在意识上想要去讨厌自己的身体或外表。然而我们现在却偏偏在这么做。接下来呢？如果我们已经接受了这是我们需要应对的事情，它正在阻碍我们前进、引发我们的社交焦虑、导致我们逃避生活、让我们对生活按下暂停键，那么我们能改变什么？我们实际上能做些什么呢？
Well, I drew some stuff from both the research and the psychology. the science, but also my own experience is to really guide us through. I think this past year for me has been a journey of body recognition. And, you know, I say recognition rather than acceptance or positivity, and I say that deliberately, because I really wanted it to be quite a neutral experience for me. You know, I didn't need to learn to love every part of myself straight away. That felt like a lot of pressure. I didn't need to celebrate the things immediately that I, you know, disliked for so many years because it felt artificial to, you know, do that overnight. It also felt like a huge hill to climb. So the first step was actually just getting comfortable with recognizing
好吧，我从研究、心理学、科学中汲取了一些东西，同时也结合了我自己的经验来指导我们度过难关。我认为过去对我来说的一年是一段“身体认知”之旅。你知道，我用“认知”而不是“接纳”或“积极”，我是刻意这么说的，因为我真的希望对我来说这是一个相当中立的体验。你知道，我不必马上学会爱自己的每一部分。这感觉压力太大了。我不需要立即去赞美那些我多年来一直不喜欢的事物，因为一夜之间这么做感觉很做作。这感觉像是一座难以逾越的高山。所以第一步实际上只是习惯于去认识
what my body actually looked like, actually recognizing, you know, my features, not choosing to obscure them or cover them, not looking away from mirrors or buying clothes that I knew were going to be the wrong size. You know, I had this awful habit of always buying clothes that were always buying clothes that were like genuinely two to three sizes too big for me because I didn't want to deal with the idea of like not fitting into something and thinking that I gained weight. Like I told myself to stop doing that. I actually figured out what my size was, what I actually looked like. And it didn't matter whether that was a good thing or a bad thing.
我的身体实际上长什么样，真正去认识我的特征，而不是选择去掩盖它们，不是移开视线不看镜子，也不是去买那些我知道尺码不对的衣服。你知道，我曾经有个可怕的习惯，总是买那种真的比我大两到三个尺码的衣服，因为我不想去面对自己穿不上某种衣服、觉得自己胖了的想法。我告诉自己停止这样做。我弄清了自己真正的尺码，自己到底长什么样。这无论是好是坏都无所谓。
It was a neutral. It was an honest process of just again recognition. Like the way I always put this to other people was that I was observing a painting and the colors, the technique, the shadow. the textures, and I wasn't saying anything about whether I liked that painting or not. I wasn't saying anything about how I would have done it differently. I was just observing. The second element, I think, that comes after being committed to seeing your body for what it
它是一个中立的过程。这是一个诚实的、再次去“认知”的过程。就像我经常向别人解释的那样：我当时就像是在观察一幅画，观察它的色彩、技法、阴影、纹理，我并没有去评价我是否喜欢这幅画。我没有说我会如何以不同的方式去画它。我只是在观察。我认为，在致力于将你的身体视为它
actually is, neither positively or negatively, is noticing your unhelpful appearance, assumptions or judgments, and really interrogating where they came from. Was it because you experienced, as we talked about negative events in the past, that came back and were tied to kind of a trauma around appearance? Was it that, you know, where did you learn this from? What was the experience where you first remember having a recognition that you didn't like how you looked and who told you that? Who said something?
本来面目的样子（既不积极也不消极）之后，随之而来的第二个要素是：注意你那些无益的外表假设或批判，并真正审视它们是从哪里来的。是因为你经历过——正如我们前面谈到的——过去那些不愉快的事件，它们卷土重来并与某种关于外表的创伤挂钩吗？是因为，你知道的，你从哪里学到了这些？你最初记得自己意识到不喜欢自己的外表是在什么时候，是谁对你说的？是谁说了什么？
What did you say to yourself? Is there something that you tell yourself that you must or should do in order to avoid judgment about your appearance? Why is that? Why do you tell yourself, oh, you know, I can't wear those kinds of. of jeans or like, oh no, I can't go to work without wearing makeup. Oh, you know, no, I need to get my eyelashes done on my hair dyed once a month. Why do you feel the need to do that? What negative predictions do you have around what would happen if you didn't do those things? And to go one step
你对自己说了什么？你是否总是对自己说，你必须或应该做些什么来避免别人对你的外表评头论足？为什么会这样？为什么你会告诉自己：“哦，你知道的，我不能穿那种款式的牛仔裤”或者“哦不，我不化妆就不能去上班”？哦，你知道的，“不，我需要每个月去弄一次睫毛或染一次头发”。你为什么觉得自己非得这么做？如果你不这样做，你对将要发生的事情有什么负面预测？再往前走
further, it's, you know, what is the worst thing that could occur from somebody actually noticing that floor that I try so hard to hide and I try so hard to obscure? what is the worst thing truly the worst thing that could come from somebody judging me based on my appearance they could not like you i know it sounds so obvious to say that is the worst that could happen they could just not like you they could not what give you attention they couldn't they might not give you something that you want from them but if that is a friend a love interest a colleague whoever if that is how they judge or they value you is based on your appearance if that is how they determine what you are deserving of, I have a feeling that that relationship wasn't going to
一步，那就是：你知道，如果有人真的注意到了我极力隐藏和掩盖的那个缺点，可能发生的糟糕情况究竟是什么？最糟糕的事，真正最糟糕的事，从别人根据我的外表来评判我这件事中会产生什么？他们可能会不喜欢你。我知道说出来显而易见，这已经是可能发生的最坏情况了：他们可能就是不喜欢你。他们可能不给你关注，他们可能不给你任何你想从他们那里得到的东西。但如果那是你的朋友、恋人、同事或任何人，如果他们就是这样评判你、衡量你的价值——是根据你的外表，如果这就是他们决定你配得上什么的方式，我有预感，这段关系本来也
last that long anyways. And I have a feeling that it wasn't going to be particularly fruitful. So is it actually a loss? Is it truly a loss that this person couldn't look past the most uninteresting thing about you, which is your appearance to the thing that really exists below the surface. This whole process is about really taking your irrational beliefs about your body to their final conclusion. What is the darkest place that they could go? Stop there and really assess whether that is as bad, you know, as as you tend to believe. Because often we just have this belief and we avoid really thinking about what it is that's sustaining it. And when we actually look at the underlying fears that we have and we realize how untrue or how unnecessary they are, we escape from
维持不了多久。而且我有一种预感，它也不会有什么特别的成果。所以这真的是一种损失吗？这个人无法透过你身上最无趣的部分——也就是你的外表——去看到表象之下的真正的你，这真的是一种损失吗？整个过程其实就是把你不理性的身体信念推演到最终的结论。它们可能走向的最黑暗的地方是什么？停在那里，认真评估那是否真的像你倾向于认为的那样糟糕。因为通常我们只是抱有这种信念，却回避去真正思考是什么在支撑着它。当我们真正审视内心深处的恐惧，并意识到它们是多么的不真实、多么的不必要时，我们就从
our initial compulsions. I would also say find a way to feel good in your body that doesn't have the primary goal of changing it. For example, when you exercise, instead of thinking about calories, about muscle growth, about weight loss, broaden your focus to how much better it makes you feel mentally. When you're choosing clothes, instead of always thinking about what's flattering first, think about what you would wear if you were the person you most admired. What would you dress the hottest person alive in? And why not wear those clothes yourself? Someone was telling me how they used to really see doing their makeup as a way to conceal
最初的强迫冲动中解脱出来了。我还会说，找到一种在身体里感觉良好的方式，而这种方式的核心目的不是为了改变它。例如，当你锻炼时，不要去想卡路里、肌肉增长、体重减轻，而是将你的注意力扩大到它能让你的精神感觉好多少。当你挑选衣服时，不要总是把“什么最显瘦”放在第一位，而是去想：如果你是你最钦佩的那个人，你会穿什么？你会给世界上最性感的人穿什么衣服？为什么不让自己也穿上这样的衣服呢？有人曾告诉我，他们以前真的把化妆看作是一种遮掩的手段，
and now they see it as a way to be creative, right? It's that mindset shift of focusing on what makes you feel confident despite the dysmorphia and doing more of that. retraining your brain to remember that your appearance is once again not tied to your value. There is something that matters more and that is how you feel about the world. That's feeling good in yourself. That's feeling healthy. That's your kindness, your creativity, your intelligence, your well-being.
而现在他们把它看作是一种发挥创造力的方式，对吧？这就是心态的转变：关注那些能让你在身患身体变形恐惧症时依然感到自信的事物，并做更多这样的事。重新训练你的大脑，记住你的外表再次不与你的价值挂钩。有更重要的事情，那就是你对世界的感受。那是在自我中感觉良好。那是感觉健康。那是你的善良、你的创造力、你的智慧、你的幸福感。
All of those come above. So some final tips and some lightning round advice. Every day try and find one thing to compliment about yourself that is not looks based to kind of steer your brain and your mind away from centering appearance at the core of everything else and complement others as well. Create more positive reactions in yourself by extending those kind of reactions to those around you as well. Try and break out of the narrative that your body and your appearance has to be a constant work in progress. It can be the final destination. Where you are right now can be the end goal. If your body can do what it needs to do, if it can have fun, if it can move,
所有这些都排在前面。所以，分享一些最后的建议和快问快答式的忠告。每天试着找出一件关于自己的、与外表无关的事情来进行赞美，以此来引导你的大脑和思维远离将外表作为一切核心的执念；同时也去赞美别人。通过向周围的人表达这种积极的反应，在自己身上创造更多的积极反馈。试着打破那种认为你的身体和外表必须是一项“永远在进行中的工程”的陈词滥调。它可以是终点站。你现在所在的地方就可以是最终的目标。如果你的身体能做它需要做的事，如果它能玩乐、能活动、
if it can dance, if it can laugh, if, you know, if it can love, that's it. Great. It's done everything that it needs to do. You don't need to improve it beyond that. You don't require anything more from it. You don't have any further demands. Speak to your body as if the person you are speaking to is that childhood version of yourself who probably first encountered the belief that they didn't like something about their appearance. If you were, if you knew what you knew now, and you were speaking to that child version of yourself in this moment, what would you be saying?
能跳舞、能大笑、如果它能去爱，那就够了。太棒了。它已经完成了它需要做的一切。你不需要在此之外去改进它。你对它没有任何更高的要求。你对它没有任何进一步的需求。跟你的身体说话，就好像你正在对那个童年时期的自己说话——那个可能最初遭遇“觉得自己外表某处不好”信念的自己。如果你——如果你知道现在的这些，并且在此时此刻正与那个童年版本的自己对话，你会说些什么？
And are the things that you would be saying to that version of you, that five, six, seven year old version of you, that sweet, innocent person, would you be saying to them what you were saying to yourself? Would you be as harsh? Would you be looking in the mirror, seeing that childhood version of you reflected back and saying, wow, you really need to do something about X,
你对那个版本的自己——那个五岁、六岁、七岁的版本，那个甜美、纯真的自己——所说的话，会是你对自己说的那种话吗？你会那么严厉吗？你会照着镜子，看着那个童年版本的自己在镜中反射，然后说：“哇，你真的得对X做点什么，
or you're not going to be happy until you change Y, or like that's revolting, that's disgusting. Of course you wouldn't. So why are you saying that to yourself now? That version of you, that innocent, you know, unashamed version of you still exists and still deserves to be alive and present in the version of you now that is an adult. and every time we are harsh and critical and unkind to ourselves,
不然你永远不会快乐，直到你改变Y”，或者“太反胃了，太恶心了”？你当然不会。那你为什么现在对自己说这些话呢？那个版本的你——那个天真无邪、毫不羞耻的版本的你——依然存在，并且依然值得在现在的这个已经成年的你身上活得鲜活、真实。每一次我们对自己严厉、苛刻、刻薄，
I do honestly believe that we kill a little part of us that is quite pure and quite happy. So that is kind of my final reminder for the day. I really hope that this episode has brought you something, whether that is information, whether that is peace, whether that is closure, community, a sense that other people are going through, what you are going through, I promise you are not alone.
我真的相信，我们都扼杀了一小部分相当纯粹、相当快乐的自我。所以这就是我今天的最后提醒。我真心希望这一集能为你带来一些东西，无论是信息、平静、释怀、社群感，还是一种“别人也正在经历你所经历的一切”的感觉——我向你保证，你并不孤单。
This is so much more common. I don't know if that's a good thing, but at least it doesn't feel as solitary. And I just hope that you're taking care of yourself and that you're choosing to be kinder to yourself as a result. So again, thank you for listening. If you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify, wherever you are listening right now. It really does help the show to grow and to reach new. people. Make sure you are following along. If you liked this episode, we have hundreds more that might be of use, but whatever you're going through. And if you have a suggestion, if you have
这种情况太常见了。我不知道这算不算一件好事，但至少不会让你觉得那么孤立无援。我只希望你能照顾好自己，并因此选择对自己更温柔一些。再次感谢大家的收听。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请随时在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评。这确实对节目的成长和触达新听众大有帮助。确保关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，我们还有数百集可能有用的节目供你收听。无论你正在经历什么，如果你有建议，如果你有
feedback, if you have, you know, something you want to say about this episode, you can follow me at that psychology podcast. We would love to hear from you. Until next time, be kind to yourself. Please be gentle with yourself. And we will talk soon. 2%. That's the number of people. who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness,
反馈，如果你对这一集有什么想说的，你可以在That Psychology Podcast关注我。我们很期待听到你的声音。下次见前，对你自己好一点。请对你自己温柔一些。我们很快再聊。《2%》。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神韧性、健身，
and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the I-HartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. on The Look Back at it podcast.
以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更-健康的人。收听《2%》。这就是TWA%在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方。在《Look Back at It》播客中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians,
从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个大时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员
and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Keir Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast, In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
你正在收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何其他地方都真的不安全进行的坦诚对话，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个恶作剧。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格、莱斯利、迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, news, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to LoveTraft podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，新闻显示劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。本集暂无评论。点击转写文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。